nun kämpfen sie wieder um die
vorherrschaft in einer fernen galaxie
und wenn wir nur genug daran glauben ist
alles wahr
war alles
futuristisch unterwegs ist auch thomas
sedlacek der tschechische ökonom ist ein
großer fan der star wars saga
er teilt mit ihr das geburtsjahr 1977
es ist der ewig gültige mythos von gut
gegen böse
welche seite am schluss obsiegt bestimmt
eine unsichtbare unfassbare kraft
die im hintergrund die geschicke lenkt
das weltraum märchen hat längst die
kinderzimmer der welt erobert auch das
der familie siedlaczek in prag zur
unverhohlenen freude des vaters ich
kaufe das gern weil ich es eigentlich
für mich drauf mit meinem achteinhalb
jährigen sohn star wars als neuer optik
wieder zu erleben das ist schon
einzigartig
es gibt kaum etwas das generationen so
zu verbinden vermag auch wenn die
geschichte in einer weit entfernten zeit
und galaxie spielt so ist sie doch sehr
vertraut thomas zach ist der querdenker
unter den ökonomen und ein gefragter
redner wie 2012 am weltwirtschaftsforum
in davos seine ökonomie von gut und böse
findet in gleichnissen aus der bibel in
märchen oder filmen oft mehr wahrheit
als im mathematischen modell jedes
gleichnis ob eine mathematische
gleichung oder ein märchen mit einem
einhorn hat grenzen
man muss die grenzen der parallele
verstehen und damit arbeiten zu können
in star wars versetzt der glaube wird er
nur genug geschult zwar keine berge aber
doch raumschiffe
also alles eine frage des glaubens auch
in der ökonomie behauptet salatic sogar
unser finanzwesen basiert auf dem
glauben zinssätze sind ein
stellvertreter für unseren glauben
kredit ist glaube die finanzkrise wurde
anfangs kreditkrise genannt 2007 und
2008 von credo glaube also war es eine
glaubenskrise und wir nannten sie sogar
so die fähigkeit einen ganzen planeten
zu vernichten ist nicht gegen die stärke
die macht verleiht uns mit ihrem kinder
scheint von der magischen macht ich
finde ihren mangel an glauben
beklagenswert und mangelt es an glauben
und wir finden dass beklagenswert geld
hat sowieso etwas unfassbares das sieht
man nicht nur anhand der kreditkarte
wunderbar sagte nationalbank präsident
das sind 500 1 5 hundert
sagt er 5000 zum selben stück papier ist
es 5000 wert oder 100 es ist was wir
sagen dass es ist oder worauf wir uns
einigen dass es ist nun gibt es das
kontaktlose zahlen momentan sehr beliebt
wenn ich beispielsweise ein handgriff
dann sage ich dem verkäufer beim
bezahlen an terminal sie brauchen mein
geld nicht auf geld wird unsichtbar
ihr braucht seinen ausweis nicht zu
sehen wir worden sein aus nicht zu sehen
das sind nicht die grünen die ihr sucht
das sind nicht die treuen die personen
er kann passieren
weiterfahren
am ende siegt der glaube über das
beweisbare eine höchst interessante
erkenntnis für den ökonomen weil man
eine ideologie ersetzen reichen fakten
nicht man braucht dazu eine andere
ideologie
das scheint mir auch für den
kapitalismus und vielleicht sogar für
die demokratie zuzutreffen
wir wollen nicht mehr richtig daran
glauben haben aber nichts besseres woran
wir glauben kann
also bleiben wir dabei
letzte frage herr sailer check wer ist
eigentlich ihre lieblingsfigur
vielleicht solo
er ist cool und ist nicht die hauptfigur
dann bestimmt alle fans wird es freuen
der glaube an die macht wird sobald
nicht sterben zumindest der an die macht
des marktes
denn altgediente stars verkaufen sich
immer gut
wir sind zu hause das erwachen der macht
noch vor weihnachten in unseren kinos